this is over several years
you know you might go detecting all day
long and find nothing
Morris has been looking for Hidden
Treasures for more than 30 years
but for him it's way more than just a
hobby
in the worst hunting isn't it and then
you find something and you think
a spin in the ground so long and
eventually you buy books to find out
what the dress was like what the
artifacts you're finding are and um just
grows on you really but if what he finds
turns out to be a treasure under the law
he's not allowed to just keep it
first he has to see if any museums want
to buy it and the government is changing
the law to expand the types of artifacts
it will apply to well at the moment the
definition says that an object has to be
a precious metal and it has to be over
300 years old we want to bring that down
to 200 years old say that it could be
made of any metal but also have a new
test for significance
the move was prompted after discoveries
like this fell outside of the scope of
the treasury act making it harder and
more expensive for museums to acquire
this is the beerus botanicus it depicts
a wooden cloak which was exported out of
Britain during the Roman Empire it's
thousands of years old and unique but
under old laws it wouldn't be considered
a treasure and that's because it's not
made out of gold or silver
but under the new law this wouldn't
matter its cultural significance would
be enough to Define it as treasure a
plus for museums
but maybe not for Maurice who worries
that he won't be able to keep what he
now finds
that's all part of a hobby isn't it if
you took everything away it'd be no
point in it but the government hopes it
will have the opposite effect intending
for even more ancient artifacts to see
the light of day in public collections
rather than private ones Sherman Freeman
Powell Sky News